[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Welcome to "Assistant on Air."
We have conversations
with people that
build for Google Assistant.
I'm Jessica Dene Early-Cha.
And I'll be your host today.
I'm a developer advocate
for Actions on Google,
which means I create content
to teach developers on how
to build for Actions on Google.
And I get their feedback to
make the platform better.
Today, we'll be
chatting with Dan Myers.
Welcome, Dan.
DAN MYERS: Thanks.
Glad to be here.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: So
what do you do here at Google?
DAN MYERS: So I'm a developer
advocate on the Google
Assistant and Actions on
Google developer platform
team where I work
specifically on smart home.
So controlling and
automating your house
using different IoT devices
through Google Assistant.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Oh, that
sounds like such a cool, cool
space to be in.
And so the only
smart thing I really
know about and that I use
everyday is my lights.
So can you go in more
into detail about what's
happening there?
DAN MYERS: Absolutely.
So when you are developing
any type of smart device
with Google Assistant,
there's a specific flow
that you have to go through.
So when a user says a command
or says a different phrase
to control their light,
what's actually happening
there is the Google
Home or Google Home
Mini is taking in the audio.
It sends this up
to Google's cloud
for processing the natural
language understanding engine.
At that point it actually
goes to a partners cloud
for who that device is.
So for example, if it was a
Philips Hue light bulb, right?
It would actually be going
to the Philips cloud service
with a specific
structure of JSON
that matches the intent
of what the user said.
So if they said,
"turn on my light,"
there's a specific
structure in JSON
that is sent to
Philips Hue servers.
And Philips then takes that
and processes that information
and sends it back down
to the light bulb.
So it's all done through Wi-Fi
and internet connectivity.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
And that sounds awesome.
So what happens if
I'm a developer,
and I have my own
thing that I want
to connect my Google Assistant?
Is that possible?
DAN MYERS: It is.
It is.
So we have a variety
of tools for developing
your own smart devices,
both in Node.js and Java.
All of these different
libraries come
with samples, come with
tutorials on how to build it.
And so when
developing for those,
we have a list of
different device types
and a lot of different elements
for this when developing.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
So I'm assuming
because you said "device types,"
does those device types mean
that there's different
functionalities for each device
that's possible?
DAN MYERS: Yes.
So the device type itself
defines what type of icon
might show up in different
applications, things like that.
And then there's device traits.
And the device trait
is what actually
is used to define the
capabilities of that device.
So when you think
of a smart light,
you could have a light bulb
that can turn on and off.
You might have one that can dim.
You might also have one
that can change colors.
And so-- or you could even
have one that does all three.
Right?
And so each of those are
defined in different traits
within the smart home
library and given to Google
during the sync process.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
So if I'm a developer,
and I'm building my own,
I'm doing my own thing,
do I have to worry about
anything outside of just
the functionality and
seeing the functionality?
Or do I still have
to worry about how
users might ask for this?
Like, how to work with my device
I've just made or connected to?
DAN MYERS: Right.
This is the beautiful
part of Google Assistant
for smart home is that
Google Assistant handles
that natural language
understanding for you.
So as long as you have all of
those capabilities defined,
Google Assistant is able
to take that and apply
literally the infinite
number of phrases
that people can say to
control that capability.
So anything from "turn down
the lights just a little bit,"
right, to, "make it 50%
less bright in the room."
Right.
It's able to understand these
different kinds of phrases
and be able to control
it appropriately.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
Oh, that sounds great.
For me, that just
means as a developer,
I can focus on my
own thing and not
have to worry about all that.
Because that's a
lot of overhead.
DAN MYERS: Absolutely.
And that's-- I mean,
when you talk about NLU,
that's a whole
other nut to crack.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: No, no.
Definitely.
So if I am--
I'm excited.
I'm watching this video.
What's the first thing I
should do as a developer?
I want to get on-boarded.
Is there something I
should go to first?
DAN MYERS: My approach
would be to instantly go
to the code lab.
The code lab is a
complete walkthrough
of every aspect from
setting up your Google Cloud
project to setting
up on the Actions
on Google console to
setting up your Firestore.
Every aspect of developing
a smart washing machine.
So you get to see exactly what
goes into a process like that.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA:
That sounds awesome.
Well, thank you, Dan, so
much for hanging out with me
and chatting with me.
I really appreciate it.
DAN MYERS: Thank you.
JESSICA DENE EARLY-CHA: Thanks.
If you liked today's show,
please like the video.
If you have any
comments or suggestions
on what we just
learned about today
or what you want to learn
about in the future,
please find the comments below.
And feel free to
follow us on Twitter
for any updates and new videos.
I've been Jessica.
And chat with you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]